Since her parents got a divorce, Anna has had to help her mother.
In her mother's absence, Anna takes care of Grace, the baby.
At first, Anna thought it was an easy job.
One afternoon, Anna played with Grace.
She meowed like a cat and Grace imitated her.
In fact, Grace reproduced every sound that Anna made.
She took her sister outside.
She put Grace in the wagon, but there was nowhere for them to go.
So they went back inside.
Anna put the infant on the floor and went into her room.
But when she came back, Grace had vanished!
Anna looked everywhere, but she could not find her sister.
Maybe the baby had been kidnapped!
"Where are you?" Anna called aloud.
The situation was becoming urgent.
She wanted to call her mom,...
...but she didn't want her to think Anna couldn't do the job.
Anna sat down.
What was she going to do?
But then, Anna heard something.
It was coming from her room.
"Grace?" She got down on her knees and looked under the bed.
She could see Grace's bald head.
Grace had followed Anna into her room and crept under the bed.
"What a relief!" Anna cried.
She picked up her sister and patted her on the head.
Her head was soft and had no wrinkles.
Grace was sucking on a thumb and looked tired.
So Anna wrapped her in a blanket and sang rhymes for her.
Then she put Grace in bed for a nap.
After that afternoon, Anna knew that taking care of Grace was not an easy job.
It takes a lot of work to take care of a baby!